let's get into it alright so this is
gonna be a lot this is my topic
um Microsoft versus the FTC in court you
know we tried I personally have tried to
avoid this stuff but shout out to addict
and everything and you guys say look we
got to talk about it so much stuff that
came out
um I'm not gonna go through everything
but what I'm gonna try to do is go over
some key points so things that we
learned perfect yes but I will be
talking for a while so please bear with
me anyway so look uh one of the first
ones is that Court proceedings reveal
Activision Force Xbox into a better
Revenue share for Call of Duty Sarah
Bond testified that uh Bobby kotec
demanded special treatment specifically
a favorable Revenue share and threatened
to pull Call of Duty from Xbox platforms
if Microsoft didn't agree and they
basically said they you know they kind
of acquiesce because they felt that Xbox
players they wanted to keep that their
expectations met they originally only
gave her 80 okay they said they
occasionally do 80 20 Revenue split
which I believe that was asked for
rather than the traditional 70 30 which
they normally give but they felt it was
critical to getting that contact content
number two when they chose the right one
yeah number two an email from
PlayStation CEO Jim Ryan
was shared in court and reported on by
IGN um it showed that Jim was
unconcerned about Microsoft's
acquisition of ABK in the email I
believe dated uh January 20th 2022 two
days after Microsoft announced the
intent to purchase Activision Blizzard
Ryan's relaxed attitude at the deal at
the time counters his public facing
concern comments since then that emerged
in a year and a half that followed so
basically produced that
um who IGN produced
what is Snitch they just revealed what
the it's called snitching
I don't know why we getting IGA
it's just I'm just saying Okay so gonna
win out there
all the letters said as far as what Ryan
wrote in the email is that um it's not
an XBox exclusive exclusivity play at
all so he said that and he said they're
thinking better than that meaning Xbox
they have the cash to make moves like
this I've spent a fair amount of time
with both Phil and Bobby over the past
day I'm pretty sure we will continue to
see Call of Duty on PlayStation for many
years to come we have some good stuff
cooking keep your eyes peeled I'm not
complacent and I'd rather this hadn't
happened but we'll be okay more than
okay so clearly the statement is a stark
contrast the statements he has made
since then and this was in that email
day two Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive it's called to the stand we
discussed that the console Wars are a
social construct doesn't want to count
his community out but that Xbox is in
third place he said Sony is an
aggressive competitor that spends its
revenues on doing things to try and
reduce X box survival on the market he
also said Sony is actively signing
third-party games to skip our platform
and that's when he was questioned over
Microsoft acquiring exclusive content
then point four Phil went on to reveal
that they acquired Bethesda after
learning that Starfield might become a
PlayStation exclusive Phil revealed that
Sony regularly plays pays competitors to
skip the platform and Microsoft felt it
needed its own Bethesda to compete to
own competition compute Phil States when
we acquire Cinemax one of the impetus
for that is that Sony had done a deal
for death Loop and ghostwire to pay
Bethesda to not ship those games on Xbox
so the discussion about Starfield when
we heard that Starfield was potentially
also going to end up skipping Xbox we
can't be in a position as a third place
console where we fall further behind on
our content ownership so we had to
secure content to remain viable in the
business we also learned that Phil is
the decision maker on XBox exclusive
exclusivity also as a result we also
learn bethesda's Indiana Jones will be
exclusive to Xbox so that was another
one uh 0.5 out of all these things I
love everything I said we got six points
but this is what I was another major
bong show Phil Spencer swore under oath
that Microsoft won't pull Call of Duty
from PlayStation it's Phil committed to
keep Call of Duty on Playstation to the
FTC loyal multiple times arguing that it
doesn't make Financial sense to pull the
game from solely's platform and it would
harm the Xbox brand if it do if it did
so I would raise my hand he says I would
do whatever it takes he told judge
Corley in court my commitment is and my
testimony is that we will continue to
ship future versions of Call of Duty on
Sony's PlayStation 5 and he went on
further because I think the lawyer went
on to say hey so you know like just
PlayStation 5 and basically said for any
further iterations of playing whatever
happens to these dudes
whatever they happen to turn into if
they happen to be an app
so he went on to stake that game
whatever he's provided that somebody
accepts the deal right that they will
continue to do this if you don't bend
the knee you don't get it B
so you ain't put it put the weight on it
you know I'm saying so um yeah he swung
the oath without looking at any future
terms that need the FTC asked further
can you swear under oath without without
looking at any future terms that need to
be hashed out you'll ship all versions
of Call of Duty that may exist on all
versions of PlayStation that may exist
in the next 10 years feels dominance
Maximus it really expensive says that's
my goal yes so that was huge under oath
and yeah that wasn't amazing it was way
more stuff but there's a kind of the
major ones that's the gist of it and
yeah a lot to unpack here so any
standouts for y'all this week how we
feeling about all this information let's
start with you Lord addict you know you
brought this to my attention about the
Final Fantasy stuff you brought a lot of
stuff to my attention you actually pay
more attention
because people keep tagging me in the
stuff on Twitter like if anything I've
seen in this is uh Sony played
themselves you know PlayStation play
themselves they went out there they were
being aggressive with death Loop and uh
ghostwire Tokyo and my in the moment
they because you know they got the the
appetizers and then they looked at the
main course which was Starfield and it's
uh Xbox and feel like yeah we done we
done and not only because they went and
used those typing you know first off
Xbox has done this We're Not Gonna Act
Like Xbox hasn't done this uh but I've
never seen a company be this aggressive
doing it like shutting entire Publishers
down almost all of their games if you
think about it
there was a time where where Sony was
going to get all of bethesda's games
pretty much all the square enix's game
pretty much the majority of both of
these Publishers were going to be
exclusive or the majority of the games
were only going to be on Playstation
obviously Square Enix they've done you
know little gains for you know smaller
projects for you know the Nintendo
switch
but
what happens if Microsoft didn't buy
Bethesda yo you know is Elder Scrolls 6
going to be only on Playstation like
what is the difference between
Microsoft coming in and just buying the
studio so that can happen to them and
Playstation say we don't need a body
we're just going to lock down all your
games what's the difference because that
would have been def Loop ghostwire talk
star film elusive to PlayStation imagine
this year you that's how you circumvent
going to court right you if you're just
buying games the FTC and everybody else
they don't care about it yeah they don't
care about that they're doing mergers
and stuff like that see Sony is smart
enough to understand I can just hurt you
by taking away the game you need to own
her I can just get the milk right
Microsoft understood the the the grander
scheme that's why the email says what it
says but go ahead at it yeah and I think
that that's my biggest thing where it's
like look like
regardless what happened Sony brought
this on themselves they they're going
out there being very aggressive and it's
one thing and not only mentioned that
they get in the timed exclusions they're
also locking down missions locking down
content added games you know they did it
with Destiny for years they're doing it
right now with uh they did with Marvel's
Avengers with Spider-Man they're doing
it with uh and then people say well you
know Spider-Man uh that that's their
title they they have every then why was
it in Midnight Suns why was Spider-Man
on Xbox and midnight Sons so clearly
they could have been in Marvel Avengers
but Sony stepped in and and made sure it
was only on there well they could keep
that Spider-Man though oh that's the
Zumba class yeah
Xbox One with that one
and you know because they were so
aggressive and they were you know
locking down whole Publishers Microsoft
had to be more aggressive and you know
Microsoft did this in the 360. they did
a I would say they did a lighter
approach than than PlayStation did in
the PS4 you know they got stuff like
Mass Effect Bioshock they did get a few
exclusive content on their platform but
it seems like Sony locking down whole
publishing get arms like all of them
yeah so it's just like Microsoft was at
its position after the 360 where they
saw this happen and they're like we're
not gonna go back and do that again
because what's gonna happen
is we're going to pull up Bethesda snap
star field we're gonna pull up to
Activision snatch a couple years of
marketing for Call of Duty and snatch
maybe the next Crash Bandicoot and then
what's gonna happen they're gonna be
like oh well we don't want to work with
you on Elder Scrolls 6. you know the the
price of the brick went up it was a
match success so it's just like
terminology PlayStation X PlayStation
put Xbox in a situation where
we got all this money in the bank do we
really want to deal with other people
that own the IPS that we work with do we
really want to have another cryotic
situation where we got to negotiate with
them on who owns rides yeah no we're not
doing that so they just bought the whole
company because PlayStation's being
aggressive like that the consequence is
what now they're not getting star filled
they're not getting Indiana Jones right
but guess what if PlayStation bought
these companies no one would even
question
you very interesting you know very yeah
and it's just like as far as like the
Final Fantasy stuff they Phil Spencer
pretty much came out there openly and
said you know they paid to have 16 not
on Xbox
yeah which I got it's just like one of
the I understand that everyone is guilty
for this
but I've never seen companies snatch
entire companies games all of them
because if you really think about it
they they didn't get redfall because
that probably wasn't enough in
development where they see a clear
picture of what it was going to be at
the time imagine if they didn't buy
Bethesda yeah they'd be in trouble no
star filled this year going to be
exclusive to PlayStation on top of
Starfield yeah it's just like look like
I remember PlayStation just has such a
dominant effect on the industry that the
only way to truly compete and people say
oh they could keep making great games
they can but at the end of the day
Google try to pop in and snatch a bunch
of stuff didn't work out for them
they're doing Amazon's do like Luna
right now you know and I get that's not
traditional console making it is not
easy to compete with a company like
PlayStation and Nintendo or Waverly
Brown going at you he said he said but
it's a good thing when Xbox buys old
Publishers that's right it is because
it's the same thing
look the only difference is one wrote a
bigger check than the other well one
that's the only thing y'all wanted them
to compete right shut up
don't want them to compete but y'all
don't want the deal to go through now we
want to compete
don't sit there and say oh no you know
Microsoft y'all should not do no do not
be opposed to it be for it so you just
the funny thing is
when the company that that owns like war
or frame and all of them when they were
bought guess who's one of the bidders
king the PlayStation we heard Bethesda
was a they were bidding on Bethesda we
heard they were bidding on Warner
Brothers it seems like the only the only
person you should blame is Sony for
losing the bids they ain't got the money
that's like going to the strip club with
a bunch of honey
and you win a thousand dollar section
they put in the eBay bid y'all
it's like let me go to the ATM real
quick no they got nothing in that 18
okay hey yo Microsoft didn't buy it now
it's like at the end of the day
PlayStation's been bidding on all of
these companies they just keep getting
outbid by all the trillion dollars we've
already refuted organic once Bunchy was
was purchased that kind of destroyed all
that it comes down to it's like you know
people say well PlayStation's not
worried about Xbox dude then why do they
keep bidding on the same damn companies
but Xbox is bidding on because they know
what's going on here it's not a
coincidence that they never really you
know uh grew their company to this
degree to play Xbox started dropping
billion here a billionaire and buying
all these companies because Sony has
always feared micro solved in this area
but Microsoft has never put this kind of
money into the industry and now that
they are doing it Sony is happening to
escalate their stuff okay you know
insomnia
who says a place if Microsoft never
would have bought those companies in
2018 would they have bought uh insomnia
games it's debatable they wouldn't if
they would have kept working with them
close by and never actually committing
and fully buying the company that's why
it irritates me when people sit there
and they act like Sony's not scared of
the Landscaping of the business uh I
guess what a king it's it's in Sony
working their way towards a cloud
disputing type of uh technology aren't
they doing that yeah well you know you
know imitation is a sincere
let's get this little fake console thing
they gonna put out let's drum up some
business over here for our cloud service
for this PlayStation 5 that seems to be
lacking
Jim knows what's up um I'll get to it I
don't want to I don't know let me finish
we got 1400 almost 1500 people here oh
let's go listen listen man come on now
we need to save the Bronx snake
just the regular snake in a box
the reason I was late coming into this
you know it wasn't because I was playing
Final Fantasy 16. I'll tell you that
right now oh okay it's because I was too
busy locking up King [__] wow
we we we have this key it's called a
thousand likes and that that comes
undone you know look wild it's been
locked into the best
you can't come out okay I I have
myself built the key oh wow
Supernatural season five yeah that's
what I did wow and until that gets to a
thousand likes hey stay in there
you're on an interesting line of a
thought process with this whole Saudis
movement I was gonna ask you like so in
your opinion based on the way Sony was
moving with locking I said all these
exclusive we found out about Starfield
you know do you feel they were because
right now the talk is we're doing this
whole thing because we're worried about
the fcc's doing this whole thing because
we're worried about harming competition
right competition you know that this
deal would harm the scope do you feel
that if this deal I mean didn't happen
if somebody was allowed to do all that
you know um software purchases and so on
and so forth with exclusive that they
were on a mission to harm Xbox or to get
them out of there because that's what
I'm saying some of the talk as well do
you agree with that are you saying that
as much that's all hyperbole
I feel like PlayStation was my do what
PlayStation does best you know they they
compete when they see Microsoft stepping
up their competition
they can't do what Microsoft does let's
keep that 100 you know they could buy
Square Enix they could buy companies
like that but the difference is it's
easier it's like I said multiple times
it's easier to convince your board
members to drop eight billion dollars
when you got 50 million 50 billion in
cash Sony could easily get the money to
buy a corporation like that they could
they can raise billions of dollars they
have plenty of assets they could use
that against it but the problem is is
it's a huge risk to ask your board
members yo let me let me uh let me spend
like 30 percent of what our com whole
damn company's work let me spend 30
percent and go buy this hopefully it
will work out for the best so what do
they do the next best thing okay
Microsoft go out there they can throw
out that money and be buying all these
companies we're gonna strategically
plant
games where we see fit and I feel like
you know it started with the Final
Fantasy 7 remake yeah they saw success
there then they're okay let's see what
else we can do you know we can't buy
Bethesda but we can snatch death Loop
right we can snatch Ghost Squad Tokyo
and then we could stat star filled and
Microsoft heard that because I think
Microsoft
before if they never would have
approached them for a star foot I don't
think Microsoft would have revolved
Bethesda because I I think that when it
was just Square Enix Microsoft was like
that's a Japanese company helping a
fellow Japanese company with business
they've worked in the past right it
makes perfect sense but then when Sony
crosses the pond
okay just looking at my girls
looking at your girls but when you come
across that street to my projects
get up out of here
and that that's why I feel when we heard
star film might be exclusive to
PlayStation they're like look even if
it's just one game two games three games
we're talking years of development that
one game is equivalent to three years of
making three to five years of making
that okay by the time that studio gets
around to making almost if not almost
the end generation is gonna be over
we're gonna be in the next Generation
keep in mind star flow took like five
years to make so by the time their next
game comes out we're going to be in the
next generation and with one investment
Sony could have snatched that whole
generation of that game yeah all we know
Starfield could be the next great thing
the next game of the decade and
Microsoft and Sony was willing to take
the risk to try to make those an
exclusive now Sony don't have really the
the free money to go in there and just
be dropping money and stats in the whole
company I think they would probably be
more up to it now because Microsoft's
doing it but I do think part of them's
like this publisher things over you know
even if Microsoft buys Activision I
think in the back of their head
Microsoft's never gonna try this again
like I feel like if Microsoft comes out
at the with the w at the end of this
Activision deal Sony and Microsoft no
we're probably not gonna do this
a big publisher like Activision Ubisoft
yeah yeah I see I get where you're going
with it they're not gonna go and get
like
um what's that uh Embrace a group right
they won't do that but they go to
embrace them but like remember the stuff
I asked you to hold
the night over here oh yo Sega you know
how we do let's go so little things like
that say and then one Sega separates
they sell from those pachinko machines
and all that other stuff they already
separated yeah this is what I'm talking
about they already got themselves
prettied up right they ready for the
wedding
again her eyebrows done the lashes and
since
yo and Microsoft just want to do this
and the last thing I'll say before I
hand it off to so I've got to get his
boss
the best thing that came out of this is
Indiana Jones hell yeah because you know
what's crazy you know what's crazy if
you really sit there and you think about
it if you really think about it and now
that we know this game because even
myself I was told it was an exclusive
but even I was told by a person I trust
but I said you full of it because I was
convinced this game was a multi-plat and
the fact that they had this in the
chamber and never shot it publicly yeah
it's crazy they could have easily
Imagine This
open up last uh the the next episode
three or whatever it is has an Indiana
Jones amazing Gameplay at the end it
says XBox exclusive the the the stadium
would have would have went crazy
look we got to get some of his boss he's
been very patient I was so happy when it
was like it's exclusive
we got about 280 or buck don't get out
oh [__] they almost there oh yeah 280.
well no okay it's like close to 300
likes we need from you guys or I'm Gonna
Keep Buck locked up I don't care buckles
[Music]
got some PlayStation stuff
making content exclusive Lord addicts
man
this guy here anyway Lord saw a lot to
unpack tons of Bombshells news where you
at with this whole situation how you
feel about some of this information
that's come out I think you know we've
been talking about this for so long now
that what a lot of people aren't really
addressing is the finality of what's
Happening Here Right One Way or Another
Something's Gonna Go Down finally right
maybe next week or maybe next week right
as soon as next week right so the
finality of it is what makes it
interesting because now all the cards
are on the table all the dirt is getting
slung and and when you see it see this
is the thing right
we're all looking at the proceedings and
the things that we're hearing how stupid
some of these questions are that they're
asking and it feels like it's the blind
leading the blind and when you think
about the the the court system in the
United States there's a lot of that that
happens on every level whether it be
something like this or the corporate
level or whether it be on the on the
ground level with you know somebody
going to jail for x amount of time for
something they didn't do because of
incompetence uh so my thing is listening
to all these arguments right and in the
back of my mind also thinking that it
might be a political agenda behind this
I'm just like I don't know I I really
don't know if it the obvious thing that
we're seeing right is going to come to
pass and the right thing is going to
happen which is the injunction should
not pass because the the arguments are
weak right the arguments are just weak
and for no other reason other than the
arguments are just weak but I just don't
have faith in the system okay that is
going to happen right so I'm just like
I'm looking at this and I'm like okay I
know that micros they're not dumb you
know they have a plan B a plan C a plan
whatever if this doesn't go through
right and it's any number of different
permutations of the things that we've
been talking about where you break off
Call of Duty or you buy this you know
again uh you haven't embrace it holding
on to the homie
yeah no you're absolutely right so um I
just I do it's interesting and it's kind
of exciting because there's going to be
finality to this and I don't know that
it's gonna go the way that we think it's
going to go based on based on just
politics based on just politics and the
fact that we're looking at it as Gamers
that people understand and and talk
about industry and we know that these
arguments seem stupid and bogus but it
doesn't matter if there's an agenda and
as an agenda it is not going to matter
right so that ultimately is the most
interesting I think when when looking at
the specific stuff that's come out
um the stuff that like made me raise
eyebrows which was really the Bobby
codic stuff
the strong arming and and again Xbox put
themselves in this position right with
the Xbox one they did right sure they
they had this relationship before during
the 360 generation it did not have that
leverage anymore in the Xbox one
generation so I get it but to the point
where it's weird that Bobby would be
like hey this thing that it that that
that does numbers everywhere nah you
need to give me this much money for me
to even think about putting it on your
platform yep and and that is that and
also you have to pay that much money
once the other guys aren't paying yeah
right and you can't talk about it on
your platform as if it's going to your
platform until x amount of time you've
got the marketing rights and they strong
it's like that was the if think about
gangster that was that's that's the guy
bro that's the official king that's a
where we from that's a stick it's like
yo what you gonna do you know it's like
you go in the store the dude like okay
let's say you brought to Arizona yeah so
Sony goes in and Buys in Arizona for 99
cents
you go in there and put your Arizona on
the counter and the dude say about 50.
and you said what what I'm thirsty it's
hot
it's hot you shut up and you give me the
buck 50 and then you get out my store
yeah so either you drink or you go yeah
what you're going and you got to pay the
Bucks you're thirsty yeah you're thirsty
You Got No Label on Arizona your logo
ain't nowhere near it they don't promote
it bro
was like yeah we bent the knee yes we
bent the knee because they figured they
say yeah they could not to to Delight
their customers right they knew the
importance of having Call of Duty on the
platform for them to not have and the
fact like you said so think about the
bluff that's called let's just say like
Microsoft didn't want to do it think
about how gangster you got to be as
activist to be like so what if they say
no yeah that's kind of crazy dude you
ain't on a lot of stuff yeah you'll just
be another one
and then turn around like you don't even
we don't sell on your platform anyway we
don't care like you know it's it's mud
slinging back and forth right
um but again business prevailed and the
right business move was to bend the knee
even though they were being stronger
um so just that the whole idea when you
think about all of that right and then
for the dime to turn completely be like
yeah we're on the same time you think
about the relationship right yeah that's
the existed relationship so you think
about the how how frivolous and and and
that that business dealings are like you
could you could be enemies quote-unquote
enemies and if and if the numbers right
that's all gone because they're just
like a little bit different
um when I get to when I don't want to
jump in the segment okay it's a little
bit different I I believe I have a
different theory on that yeah my only
thing I was going to jump in was just
that you know now that you fast forward
then it's like oh so you're going out of
business